thank you guys it's good to be here my
name is Hans Kim, I live in a van so
that I can pursue comedy full-time. I
think comedy is pretty serious business
I love comedy but sometimes I wish I was
a painter cuz I've never been painting a
picture and have the canvas be like
boo that doesn't look like a tree you should quit
draw something Asian. I am pursuing
comedy full-time so if you don't think
I'm funny I'm sorry I'm trying really
hard
I know someone's in the back like yeah
that's funny but not live in your van
funny. could've written that joke in an apartment buddy
it's very difficult to date inside of
a van. Until you get them in there it's all
about the push.
No I'm kidding. I don't... I had consensual sex in my van recently. And uh it was very nice because vans are very tight quarters
I don't think I could ever go back to having sex in an apartment. It's so easy
to have sex when you can grab a boob in
the kitchen for the bedroom. Everything's
boob reaching distance. It's hard to go on
dates as a van dweller because ladies
love shelter
It's this whole thing with them. They're crazy about it.
so even if a date goes well what usually ends up happening is we go for a drive
until I can work up the courage to tell
her we arrived 45 minutes ago. Surprise were here the whole time.
I love being Asian I don't like how arrogant
Asian women are to me. They act like they're
such hot shit in America
back home we're throwing them away. You
don't impress me you just look like us. I
can throw on a wig and be a seven. it's
not hard to fuck white dudes you don't
impress me. Anyone can fuck them. I could fuck them. I just don't want to. I get made fun of a lot
people think Asians eat dogs which is
saying could be horrific
because in America dodging truth like
family members but in Asia we treat
family members like family members this
is real a little tradition we have my
vote where instead of buying an animal
we love our grandma should everyone Asia
let's share baby girl which could
survive in any will in this situation
that you put them in accept a situation
where everyone has equal rights a kind
of fuck some of
you can live in a swamp with an
alligator but hey live in a cul-de-sac
with a minority I'm pretty progressive
at the times I think trans people should
be allowed to use whatever they see my
pronouns are for spacing small cock
respect my brother's place I like to eat
General Tso's chicken my ancient friends
like it's not just a shitty Americanized
version of something like that typically
Asian and I'm like yeah that's so high
my favorite movies rush hour 3 a shoe or
as another subject Chinese
I'm from a Province in China called
South Korea
Japan province
I am South Korea so technically I am a
southerner you know I do this I like
commies some people did you know I was
kind of this racist dude it was like did
you know that the only reason black
people are bigger and stronger than
white people is because we bread then
display needs to be that way and I was
like well now it's true why don't you
use this feeling yourselves and made
yourself a good strong giving a
superpower to people who hate you
also why are you fucking your cousin's
not really the move kinetic scientists
now look inside alright